okie dokie welcome to this video playing
mr. serious I think this is yeah William
pair peschel this is a good
pronunciation let's see yeah I think
yeah this is an American i am with think
maybe lifts in hungary this is some
garion flag as well so probably i'm
right and assuming that Queen to e7 what
kind of move is that I still going for I
mean he cannot really take only for
their 95 I cannot take you for but this
looks bit tricky Bishop g5 he has to
play c6
wowhead load looks like something you
would want to refute and really refute
quickly but maybe that's not possible
simply okay i'm developing okay a
question i can go to f4 that's not out
of the question but ok let's do this
cannot really believe in GF if'n I takes
e4 there would be a really strange if it
worked
Jim but if he goes like castles I can
make him probably just go f3 and
basically claimed that queen is not well
Ani seven maybe I'd star g5 that that's
really atrocious if it would go for that
ok let's go f3 and keep them keep the
pawn for good I have simple idea as
Queen d2 d1
why is taking quite well why not just
castling it says something great here i
don't i wonder i really wonder
quindi 294 might be might be possible
yeah maybe ok ok let's go King edge one
that sets a very often a useful move
anyway once the f porn has some has
moved so what now yeah quincy two wires
for work T 1 it's not bad yeah so I can
take or can move the night away both
this interesting and that maybe take it
I can play c5 it looks irritating pawn
takes you five wins apiece ok can check
here now Bishop g3 with a channel and
then look to you one for Bishop t6 he
has not cancelled yet
so Rupert e1 next basically whatever he
does it doesn't have many Queen moves
anyway so
that looks pretty bad I honestly think
he has to Castle just just giving away
the exchange and hope for some dark
square dark square opportunities one
thing is though okay i'm really i'm
taking this opportunity here making sure
you cannot castle night a for its SI 14
95 not sure but ok I don't want to
stumble into time issues here the
pollution is so nice so night see 5 or I
mean you can still not ever castle maybe
Bishop c4 is an idea takes takes be five
okay let's do that it's not not bad it's
a more of a technical way to continue if
I of him you five if he takes Bishop
deform wins okay maybe can go Queen f5
yeah but it's still that should be good
for me there are some funny ideas here i
have calculated a funny line Queen a5
Bishop d3 Queenie five rookie one queen
bee to rookie six check every six bishop
g six mate thats a nice line oops what
ye wants to sacrifice the Queen yeah
that's possible maybe he wants to give
away the Queen it's not sufficient but I
see the idea I think the problem is that
this is a big move now I get row again
in rookie rookie won this king is just
far too insecure so we're like here for
twin b7 I guess rookie one rookies guess
it's not that easy that's not a taut so
easy maybe I should have taken maybe
yeah should have taken that that damn
pond now I'm not quite sure how to
window I should have taken upon time
warning
so when can I do something here against
against his King and steak
form check says something right probably
not it's amazing yeah I'm this Emily
okay I'm a queen up all nice but it's
not a not an easy technical win now
check check grah God offered and it's
not clear that it's a draw maybe it is a
as a fortress maybe that could be a
fortress could beam Rukia six
it could be a fortress my king cannot
really help that much auntie Kalos it's
there yeah okay shouldn't have allowed
this this in the first place from the
sun moon from this winning position yeah
that's very very nice actually for white
here and now k many ideas this is a
simple way to play with not a bad one
jigs yeah wow wow if the computer here
Bishop a six wow what a move what a move
is this so rupay six rupee one yeah the
point is a line that I mentioned this is
checkmate is made so what happens they
have a chick with the pawn then Bishop
before I'm having this wow that's great
great and this is in fact okay it's it's
better for white but not okay Quincy
five oh I missed 25m yeah you kind of
you play this rupee one almost
automatically but Quincy five is so much
stronger prepares the rope check and he
cannot escape from the middle here with
the king that was that was the win yeah
yeah this is surprisingly tricky I
should take be seven though here oops d
8 computer gives equal yeah it's
possible it's really possible that this
is this is not something that white can
win yeah I mr. i miss chances here early
on a funny line that that i had seen was
this here Bishop d3 Queenie five mukhi
one Queen takes yeah this is a line that
I mentioned during that check
life commentary this is a very cute line
yeah but didn't happen unfortunately
okay well thanks for watching